sriracha is one of the most popular hot
sauces in the world but it's more than
just a sauce the story of how this
humble hot sauce became so ubiquitous
starts with this man who came to america
as a refugee and built one of the most
successful hot sauce companies in the
world oh my
[Music]
this great big story is brought to you
by
delta when we venture out into the world
we see all that we share
[Music]
david tran is the owner of hoi phong
foods the biggest and most well-known
sriracha brand out there
today he's treating his employees to an
elaborate lunch of king crab dumplings
and yes sriracha at a popular dim sum
restaurant in arcadia california
but he wasn't always the head of a big
company david came to america 40 years
ago after fleeing his home country of
vietnam on a boat
[Music]
[Music]
my
david didn't invent sriracha variations
on the sauce are found throughout
southeast asia in fact it's named after
a town in thailand by the same name
the recipe is simple the bottle is just
eight ingredients but david's sauce has
a special ingredient
in
[Music]
foreign even though he doesn't have any
formal training in engineering david
designed many of the operations in his
factory he even designed the iconic
bottle
now
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
be people from different cultures don't
just understand david's products
they adore them
[Music]
make a difference
[Music]
my
[Music]